معنى الان من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوى
سمري ومن ظهران مراسل الجزيره عبر هواش
ارحب بكم ابدا معك نجوان ماذا بعد رصد هذه
المسيره التي يعتقد بانها قادمه من سوريا
واسقاطها ماذا بعد ذلك في اطار ردود الفعل
والتفاعلات على المستوى الاسرائيلي
نعم ازدهار بعد اسقاط هذه المسيره الليله
الماضيه يجري حاليا الجيش الاسرائيلي
تحقيقات على عده مستويات اولا يريد ان
يفحص من اين بالضبط وصلت هذه المسيره لانه
غير واضح بالنسبه للجيش الاسرائيلي فيما
اذا وصلت
كمسيره ايرانيه رغم ان كافه التقديرات
لمسؤولين امنيين وفق وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه تشير بان هذه المسيره هي مسيره
ايرانيه والجيش كذلك يجري فحوصات فيما اذا
كانت هذه المسيره مفخخه وكانت
وكان هدفها لتنفيذ عمليه هجوميه ضد اهداف
اسرائيليه او انها فقط طائره استطلاع لجمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه وهناك ايضا
احتمال يفحصه الجيش الاسرائيلي بانها قد
تكون كمحاوله استفزاز فقط للجيش الاس لهذه
المسيره التي اسقطت الليله الماضيه اسقطت
الكترونيا من قبل ما يعرف بوحده المراقبه
التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي في سلاح الجو
رغم انه استنفر مقاتلاته ومروحيات حربيه
بعد ان تم رصدها وكانت قد تمكنت هذه
المروحيه من التحليق في منطقه الجولان
السوري المحتل على بعد 25 الى 30 كيلومترا
بحسب الجيش الاسرائيلي داخل الحدود اي
انها توغلت الى هذا الحد حتى اسقطت في
منطقه مفتوحه شمال بحيره طبريه حاليا هناك
ايضا حاله من التاهب المحدود ان صحى
التعبير في منطقه
الجولان وعلى الجولان السوري المحتال وعلى
طول خط وقف اطلاق النار هناك بعض الاحيان
بحسب شهود عيان في المنطقه افادون بانه في
بعض الاحيان يكون هناك تحليق مكثف
للمروحيات الحربيه وللطائرات المسيره
الزنانه طيله الوقت في هذا الموقع لكن منذ
عده ايام بدات تساور الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه حاله من القلق بان تقدم ايران
على الرد على سلسله الهجمات المنسوبه
لاسرائيل في منطقه دمشق وحمص في الايام
الاخيره
المتتاليه ولذلك كانت هناك حاله من التاهب
في هذه المنطقه منذ عده ايام
وكان هناك ايضا يوم امس راينا بان هناك
حاله من التصعيد الخطابي من قبل المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين في الموضوع الايراني سمعنا
نتنياهو يعود ويتحدث عن ذلك في مستهل
الجلسه الاسبوعيه للحكومه وايضا وزير
الدفاع المقال يو اب جالنت الذي قال بان
اسرائيل ستواصل محاربه
فصائل الفلسطينيه الا ان تكثيف الهجمات
الاسرائيليه في الاونه الاخيره على اهداف
تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني في الاراضي
السوريه ربما هو مؤشر على ان من يقف خلف
هذه العمليه هي ايران هناك ايضا
تصعيد كما ذكرت واضح من قبل الخطاب
الاسرائيلي ضد ايران في محاوله ربما ايضا
لصرف الانظار عن الازمه الداخليه التي
يواجهها نتنياهو في ظل كل المظاهرات ضد
خطته القضائيه خطته وخطه وزير القضاء
الاسرائيلي تغيير النظام القضائي في
اسرائيل هذا من جهه
ونتنياهو معروف بانه عاده ومنذ سنوات
يلتجا الى توتير الاوضاع اكثر مع ايران
وتصوير المشروع النووي الايراني بانه
الخطر الاكبر بالنسبه لاسرائيل لكن ايضا
ربما بعد هدنه معينه انسحب تعبير الوزير
الدفاع المقال عمليا
بعد ان تحدث في الايام الاخيره او في
الاسابيع الاخيره الماضيه عن هذه الازمه
نسمعه حاليا يعود ويتحدث ايضا عما يصفه
بالخطر الايراني على اسرائيل
معنا وكما لم يقل الاسرائيليون شيئا عن
تصفيه المستشارين العسكريين في سوريا
الايرانيين فان ايران لم تقل شيئا عن
المسيره عمر هواش معنى من طهران هل هنالك
اي معلومات عن هذه المسيره التي يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه اسقطها
بالفعل زين ايران لم تقل شيئا عن هذه
المسيره لا على المستوى المركز الاستشاري
الايراني في الاراضي السوريه او حتى على
مستوى الخارجيه الايرانيه اول مؤسسه
العسكريه هنا في طهران هناك صمت من قبل
ايران تجاهها هذه المسيره التي اعلن عنها
الجيش الاسرائيلي لكن هذا زين لا يعني ان
هناك حرب مفتوحه بين ايران واسرائيل طالما
تتهم ايران اسرائيل بالقيام بعمليات ضدها
واسرائيل لا تتبنى ذلك في المقابل ايران
متهمه في اسرائيل دائما بانها تقوم
بعمليات ضدها وايران في المقابل ايضا لا
تتبنى وهذا ما يوصف هنا بانه حرب الظل او
معركه الظل بين ايران واسرائيل الان هناك
مستشاران عسكريان قتلا على الاراضي
السوريه طهران تتهم رسميا اسرائيل
بالمسؤوليه عن الهجمات التي سنه في ضواحي
دمشق فجر الجمعه وقتلت هذين هذان
المستشاره نفقى المعلومات المتوفره لدينا
الاول كان من قوات القياده السيبرانيه
التابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني والثاني
كان احد المشغلين للطائرات المسيره التي
تستخدمها ايران او الفصائل المسلحه
الموالي اليها او الجيش السوري على
الاراضي السوريه رسميا طهران تقول ان
اسرائيل تحاول تصدير ازمتها الى الخارج
المعروف هنا مثل ما تقول طهران على لسان
الخارجيه الايرانيه ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في بشكل عام تعيش
ازمه سياسيه تحت عنوان التعديلات القضائيه
وانها تريد ان تفتح مواجهه ولو كانت
محدوده او مضبوطه مع عدو خارجي سواء على
الاراضي السوريه او في اي مكان اخر مع
ايران او غيرها لاجل تصدير هذه الازمه مثل
ما طهران كذلك رسميا تؤكد ايران على لسان
الخارجيه او الحرس الثوري الايراني ان
اغتيال هذين هذين المستشارين لن يمر من
دون رد وان طهران سوف ترد في الوقت
والزمان المناسب لكن ايضا ليس معروف متى
سيكون هذا الرد او كيف هل سيكون بشكل
مباشر من انطلاقا من الاراضي السوريه او
في المساحات المائيه مثل ما اتهم الطهران
خلال السنوات الماضيه او بشكل غير مباشر
عبر فصائل توصف بانها مواليه لايران
شكرا لك
عمر هواش شكرا ايضا لمراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري كانت معنا من القدس